بالآلاف جاءوا جميعهم تقريبًا باللون
الأبيض يلوحون بالأعلام الإسرائيلية من أجل هؤلاء
المتظاهرين ، هذا احتفال عندما
سيطرت إسرائيل على القدس الشرقية
من الأردن في حرب عام 1967 ، مما أتاح لليهود
الوصول إلى أماكنهم المقدسة في
البلدة القديمة للفلسطينيين ، فهذا يمثل
البداية  عن احتلال
القدس الشرقية ، ولكن في السنوات الأخيرة ،
أصبحت المسيرات أيضًا أشبه
بمظاهرة قومية يمينية
وذريعة للعنف بين اليهود
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين الذين يشكلون
معظم السكان في هذا الجزء من
المدينة بينما كان معظم المسيرات
سلمية  غنت بعض المجموعات أغانٍ عن
الانتقام من الفلسطينيين الذين قاموا بمحو
أسمائهم ،
وذهب البعض الآخر إلى ترديد هتاف رئيس
البلدية فيليدج بيرن ، وشجعهم
وجود وزراء في الحكومة اليمينية
مثل وزير الأمن القومي
إيتامار بنفير الذي سار
إلى جانبهم عبر المدينة القديمة
وإلى الغرب.
أظهر آلاف من رجال الشرطة على الحائط مدى توتر
الوضع حتى قبل أن يبدأ المتظاهرون في
استخدام التكتيكات القاسية لتطهير
الطريق بما في ذلك على مراسل سي إن إن الكبير
بن ويدمان
[تصفيق]
ما تفعله
أيضًا استهدف المتظاهرون الصحافة وهم
يلقون الزجاجات بالحجارة والعلب على  لقد
أجبر موقفنا المراسلين على الانكفاء بحثًا عن
غطاء ،
لكن يوم القدس شهد
عنفًا أكثر خطورة بكثير مما كان عليه في
عام 2021 حيث شق آلاف الإسرائيليين
طريقهم إلى المدينة القديمة حيث أطلقت
حركة حماس الفلسطينية المسلحة
صواريخ باتجاه القدس مما أدى إلى إطلاق
11-  يوم حرب
حماس والجهاد الإسلامي هددا
المسيرة مرة أخرى إذا تم تجاوز أي من الخطوط الحمراء التي لم يتم تسميتها
ولكن هذا العام
بقيت معظم الدراما على الأرض في
اشتباكات واشتباكات وليس صواريخ في
السماء